prévue pour s'étendre tout au long de
l'année il vint voir jusqu'en 2022 si
besoin la phase de transition sec des
négociations s'annoncent déjà joyeuse à
en croire les diverses prises de parole
jean yves le drian ministre français des
affaires étrangères affirme déjà je cite
on va s'étriper pas maille avec les
britanniques
l'objectif des négociations commerciales
depuis le 1er février est d'arriver à
établir un accord de libre échange et le
match s'annonce serré entre les
négociateurs de l'ue eux et du royaume
uni david frost et michel barnier avec
plusieurs points de tension la pêche
avantage aux britanniques leurs eaux
territoriales représentent une grosse
partie du chiffre d'affaires des
pêcheurs nous pour les français c'est 30
% l'industrie financière plus la city de
londres perd avec nombre exit sa liberté
d'agir sur les marchés financières du
continent et a donc besoin d'un accord
de bruxelles reste aussi les normes
européennes que les britanniques ne
veulent pas respecter et qui concernent
énormément de produits chimiques non
alimentaire bref le match promet d'être
serré surtout si aucune des deux parties
ne veut faire de concessions dans le
tiroir cash
on préfère ne pas faire de pronostic